[Music]
we've become very very close over these
these paths however many months because
I think you have to
we didn't do like a chemistry cluster
yeah that's the thing is like usually
with that kind of relationship you do
like a reading together right
but we didn't yeah chemistry we got
lucky are you kind of forced to be like
in these really intense situations
emotionally the places we had to go
together before we might have been there
in like our real-life friendship ruined
Jules were already going there I've
never met anyone in my entire life like
Jules I think their relationship goes
through like a lot of different levels
rue honestly and immediately falls in
love with Jules she just has this want
to just make her happy and I think this
is the first time that we really get to
see rue like genuinely happy about life
there feels like there's like a little
bit of a light at the end of the tunnel
for her so I think she goes really hard
really fast
a little faster than maybe Jules is
prepared for baby just take your time
you've come a long way
you're delicate I think episode 8 is
really special because ruined Jules have
finally gotten to a place where they're
aware of their love for each other it's
roos idea to run away in the first place
she wants more than anything to be with
Jules there's nobody on Jules's level in
her eyes I think she's just repeating
and thinking about all the trauma she's
already kind of caused her family in
that split moment she just thinks about
her mom and her little sister which is
like something that we've never really
like seen her do we love them together
and we want them to finally be together
and they have this moment where it's
like oh my gosh they finally are in love
and they can run off together and then
everything just comes crashing down even
though their last moment it didn't
follow through their love still exists
we hope they make our cast have gotten
very close with each other because if
they're not like literally naked in
front of each other
it had to be like emotionally naked in
front of each other she is you'd be in
every form is the worst the best vice
birth and vice versa so it's like
there's no judge I feel like I've got
like a new sister
[Music]
you